foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
appears Morgan unscented Delight horror
and Carnage in the playground a Syrian
refugee stabs four children one of them
British and a friend's attack on a
French holiday Resort by the ladies from
the scene
also Delight Richie sunnak meets
President Biden who calls sunac Mr
President and then forgets Winston
Churchill's name is it all catching up
on President Biden will ask one of fox
news's top political experts
as Roger Waters a slam for wearing a
Nazi uniform on stage he calls it
canceled culture but is he just at his
submitted well Jewish Rock royalty Gene
Simmons is live in the studio and that
is exciting
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored there are many words of
British public Associates with Boris
Johnson's Premiership chaos parties lies
shambles scandals well they all spring
to mind the word honor is definitely not
one of them even though he remains the
right honorable gentleman a few people
have done more to dishonor the high
office he held and the country he was
supposed to serve Johnson lied to the
queen and to Parliament he bungled the
pandemic partying his way through half
of it he spent fortunes on Golden
wallpaper be defended his disgrace
cronies at every turn and he did all the
Carefree gurning grin and the sartorial
Elegance of a scarecrow there can't be
many people in British politics less
qualified to adjudicate on honor which
is why it's frankly disgraceful he's
being allowed to move ahead with his
personal resignation honors list prime
minister Rishi sunak is in Washington DC
tonight is about to Wade through
Johnson's gongs and peerages for his
cronies and mates and apparently even
his father if he can get away with it
and unsurprisingly soon X not that Keen
to talk about this
I can completely understand the interest
in this topic but all I can say is
there's a process that is currently
underway it hasn't concluded yet and
until it does it wouldn't be right for
me to comment any further
yeah but it's a process that I don't
agree with and nor do most people it
should be a very very short process to
which the answer is a rapid no Liz truss
who was outlasted by a lettuce shouldn't
even think about not knowing anybody
either but she will if you resign in
shame and disgrace dishonorably as Boris
Johnson does did and is trusted why
should you be able to then hand out
honors it's not just one final insult to
the public one last log on the giant
bonfire of all things decent that rage
through these terrible time at the top I
think it is
we'll debate that later
we'll become first with this Dreadful
breaking news from France today there
are a few things that have uphold me
more than the scenes from this
children's playground in France today in
the south east of France
which just stop you from what you're
doing and gasping utter horror they show
this Lakeside playground
in anisee a picture postcard Alpine town
where most people were relaxing in the
sun on holiday and until a Syrian man a
refugee who come via Sweden began to
unleash utter Terror graphic videos some
too horrifying to share show him
stabbing a toddler in his pram as his
screaming mother tries to defend him
the attacker who was 31 years old
deliberately attacked children again and
again he could be heard shouting in the
name of Jesus Christ
video showing running around the park
waving a knife he'd used on defenseless
children as members of the public chased
him till eventually he was subdued and
reportedly shot by police
the police say we don't know what his
motivation is yet what we do know is
that four children and two adults were
injured in the Carnage a British child
and little girls among the four children
hurt two of those children and another
are severely and critically injured well
I'm joined Now by David chasmine he's
the France supporter of the times who is
at the scene of the attack in Tennessee
and in the studio by talk to the
international editor Isabel oakshaw well
let me start with you David if I may
um it's one of those things when you
watch the video
it's utterly gut-wrenching to watch this
man charging around armed with a knife
deliberately attacking children young
kids in in prams
um absolutely is completely horrifying
and the scene that people witnessed here
this morning has left this whole town
stunned I mean I'm standing now in the
playground where the attack happened and
the noise you can hear behind me is a
demonstration by a handful of right-wing
people they've just sung the National
Anthem and they're now singing patriotic
songs uh people have come here and left
floral tributes at the place where the
children were stabbed and tonight so
four toddlers including a three-year-old
British girl are fighting for their
lives in local hospitals the prosecutor
here says that there doesn't appear to
have been a terrorist motive behind the
attack uh it was carried out by a Syrian
refugee who's been arrested uh he
described himself of to please as the
Syrian Christian and video of the attack
shows him saying uh in the name of Jesus
Christ as he launched the attack that
local people and Witnesses seem to think
that he was mentally unbalanced rather
than attacking the children for
terrorist motives yeah there seems to be
reports that I've read that he had
married a woman in Sweden he'd been
living there for 10 years or so so he
came over as a refugee a decade or more
ago there'd be no problems with
authorities at all but that he'd split
up from his wife and they had a young
three-year-old child and look it's wrong
to try and you know guess what has gone
on here in terms of motivation but you
would think but potentially mental
health issues perhaps as a catalyst of
what was going on in his own life
yeah that's right I mean the wife the
ex-wife rather has spoken to French
media she she says that she last spoke
to him four months ago and he was living
in a church here in France uh it's
believed he came here last Autumn and he
made a series of applications for Asylum
here which bizarrely were rejected on
the grounds he'd already been granted
asylum in another EU country but uh
according to his ex-wife he didn't want
to stay in Sweden because they'd
rejected his applications for
citizenship and she says that he often
looked after their three-year-old girl
when he was in Sweden and she described
him as being nice nature so I mean it
Beggars belief mental health issues May
well be the cause I think prosecutors
have still got to get to the bottom of
it the police are obviously still
questioning him and investigating judges
also so we'll we'll see what more comes
to light David thank you very much
indeed for that report from the scene
there this horrific atrocity much
appreciated thank you Isabel I mean I've
got four kids you've got kids it's we've
all been to these playgrounds it's like
a little Sanctuary isn't it you go
there's other little tiny kids running
around they're in prams you can't think
of anything more Unthinkable it is
comprehensible particularly as we learn
that the attacker is a father of a child
that age I mean you know very difficult
for anyone to perpetrate an attack like
that but least of all someone who's got
young children themselves I think the
question here is are there any broader
implications to this politically or is
this just the most horrific Act of
someone who's perhaps suffering from
schizophrenia perhaps heard voices in it
said we don't know but what we've seen
from our correspondent there is that
there are already far-right
demonstrations on the scene now the
issue of mass migration is already
pretty toxic in France France takes a
very high number of Asylum Seekers many
of them from Syria that's the top
country certainly before the Ukraine war
I don't know what the figures are now
and I think this will inflame an already
very very but on that it's interesting
because when I first saw that I thought
God this is going to be a huge political
issue never mind anything else and then
you read he he got asylum in Sweden 10
years ago it's nothing to do with it you
know that's the reality but it won't
stop it I agree exactly we've got some
uh breaking news actually Rishi suneck
is now just commented in Washington
about this incident
all our thoughts are with those affected
by this unfathomable attack including a
British child and with their families
I've been in touch with President macron
we stand ready to offer any assistance
that we can
well we're joined Now by Elena Vincent
who was on holiday in anisee she's
actually from California Elena thank you
very much indeed for joining me I
understand that you turned up at the
scene of this just after it had happened
what kind of mood was there when you got
there because this is such an appalling
thing to have unfurled
yes it it certainly is uh the mood was
one of shock
uh we were many meters away from the
actual scene of the crime it was already
a crime scene the French police were
there very quickly within four minutes
there were medical personnel there was a
Life Flight helicopter landing as I
arrived
and everybody was on their phones trying
to figure out what happened I happened
to have a live BBC feed update so I knew
the very Basics because even the news
media at that point didn't really know
what had happened
and so I just started taking photos of
the scene
I'm a former journalist and in my State
of Shock I thought well I need to do
something it might be useful to document
what's happening and so that's what I
did
it's it's sort of it's a strange story
in a sense it's very hard to work out
what motive there is so the police have
very quickly said I don't think it's
terrorism the fact is an asylum Seeker
10 years ago coming from Syria to Sweden
would suggest this is not a sort of a
media issue with someone coming from a
war zone in the last few weeks uh there
may be a domestic issue a mental health
issue he's fit from his wife and had
himself a three-year-old child we
understand it's a it's a completely
baffling story isn't it
well I personally don't find it so
baffling I find it horrific and
Incredibly sad but it seems to me that
someone from Syria coming even having
been in a state of living in another
country like Sweden which is I
understand a very lovely country for 10
years still it can have untold amounts
of trauma and the fact that he split
from his wife he had a child that was
three years old and according to news
reports here he was seen hanging out in
this park for three days
so I can only imagine the state of mind
that this person was in
um and whatever happened he snapped and
lashed out in this horrific way yeah I
don't use it in any way but I personally
feel this is a mental health crisis and
we'll wait and see what authorities say
thankfully he's alive so he can be
interviewed and hopefully they can
understand
or try to understand what drove this but
absolutely I do not think this is an
issue about immigration I do not think
it's an issue about terrorism I think
it's an issue about mental health of
which we have abundance of in this world
and it's leading to Untold problems of
violence in my own countries there are
three times as many guns as people
I partly came to Europe to get away from
the ongoing level of violence but it's
everywhere and thank God this man did
not have a gun
it would have been bloodbath I mean it's
horrible enough as it is yeah but
I know you're right I don't know I
really appreciate it thank you for your
passion I appreciate it it needs to be
said I appreciate you joining me thank
you very much you are very welcome
yeah I mean it is if he had a gun there
would have been far more people killed
young young children killed indeed I
mean I was struck by many many bits of
footage that have come out how difficult
it is for any bystander even though it's
not a gun to tackle someone with a long
knife I mean there were several people
who who tried
um there was a very brave looking adult
who had a rucksack a review who weren't
so brave by the way in the video I saw
who were not doing anything is women
were desperately trying to protect their
little kids and that's that's very
difficult to put yourself in those shoes
you hoped you would try don't you but
also equally it was so unexpected
obviously happened so fast that there
were people jogging past didn't even
realize that this was going on so truly
shocking absolutely horrific thank you
very much indeed appreciate it and since
the next prime minister which is sunak
joint press conference and President
Biden in Washington DC we'll be live
from the White House lawn for the very
latest
[Music]
foreign
what's up
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh on Central
President Biden said the UK special
relationship with the US is in real good
shape today is he hosted Rishi simak at
the White House probably better shape
than him I might politely and
respectfully argue having previously
referred to his counterpart as Rasheed
suit a Sanuk when he got the job the 80
year old commander-in-chief this time
introduced sunac as Mr President he also
completely forgot Winston Churchill's
name completely couldn't remember it in
a bizarre rambling anecdote about
Churchill prowling around the White
House so how did the big visit go down
in the U.S well joining me now to talk
about this is Washington DC is Fox News
White House correspondent Peter Ducey
Peter brilliant to have you on the
program first of all adding a touch of
rare class to our show much needed
um so I watched you in these uh press
conferences at the White House and quite
often you're taking them to task over
the physical and cognitive competence or
otherwise of the president it wasn't a
great day was it for them to show him at
his best
uh well at one point the Prime Minister
had to bail President Biden out because
he's trying to tell this story about
Winston Churchill visiting the White
House after the Pearl Harbor attack it's
a it's the stuff of Legends in
Washington DC and as the president was
kind of searching for the name Winston
Churchill sunac bailed him out and then
they kind of moved on he did
accidentally introduce him at first as
Mr President and then joked that he had
demoted him and then he he corrected to
Mr Prime Minister uh and so that does
follow that that is just about a week
after President Biden fell down giving a
Commencement Address uh in Colorado it
follows him getting the name of the
South Korean prime minister Yoon wrong
he called him uh president loon and so
it is part of kind of a long couple
weeks for the President Pierce well
let's take a little look actually a
little Greatest Hits if you like and
what you've just been talking about
well Mr President Mr President I just
demo to you Mr Prime Minister
we've got news for Russia
Chinook is now the prime minister
as my brother would say go figure
probably
a bunch of Pocketful about uh
um the former prime minister I'd like to
take baths of that anyway wandering
around at three in the morning yeah
Winston Churchill bothering uh bothering
Mrs Roosevelt yes is that you you don't
worry you won't see me that uh bothering
you and the first lady I mean at one
level Peter it's kind of funny on
another level it is it is disconcerting
for the rest of the world to watch the
commander-in-chief of the United States
of America
sort of falling apart in front of our
eyes
and and that's just that is what we see
in public we don't know what is going on
behind closed doors but you would hope
that everybody is uh is as sharp as can
be considering the things that they were
talking about they're talking about
these threats to the entire West that
Russia poses they're talking about
threats of artificial intelligence which
President Biden today described as being
like science fiction and and ways to put
together guard rails for that these are
very serious things that the leaders are
discussing and so I we don't know how it
went I'm sure that this Biden White
House doesn't really leak that much I'm
not sure how the the 10 Downing Street
staff are about letting us know what
happens in these meetings but we will
hopefully have some more details about
how the president and the PM were at
shortly I'm Peter this special
relationship the much vaunted special
relationship it's felt in recent years
more special if you're here in Britain
than it perhaps does to many Americans
these days how would you categorize the
reality of the of the so-called special
relationship the reality is as somebody
that covers the White House and
literally every single thing that
President Biden does uh it's been hard
to keep track from here of who the Prime
Minister even is over the course of the
last 18 months and I you know that a big
chunk of President Biden's diplomacy
comes at these Summits where uh the
Prime Minister and the president are
like two of seven or two of 20 they go
sit at some hotel conference room for a
half an hour we get a picture and then
you don't really hear that much about it
afterwards and so President Biden hasn't
gotten a chance to know any of the prime
ministers well enough to really have any
any sort of depth to the relationship
and maybe that'll change now uh
depending on how things shake out over
there but also over here President
Biden's up for uh re-election he just
wants stability at home I don't know how
much of a focus uh the special
relationship is going to be for him when
he's just trying to convince people in
Pennsylvania and Ohio to to back him for
a second term but how damning one of the
main reasons the special relationship
can't be that specialist we never have a
prime minister in the job long enough I
mean Liz trust lasted 44 days of an
Alexis lasted longer than she did at the
end
um Peter just want to talk about
something else that the smog issue that
New York has currently got the worst air
quality in the world and it's all coming
from these wildfires in Canada
um how bad is it even in DC I'm told you
can smell stuff it's weird it's like the
air it's not right but but New York is
looking apocalyptic I this morning
walking out of my car into the White
House the air smelled like about nine or
ten years ago when I was covering the
Baltimore riots like there was something
right here that was on fire and I think
it is extraordinary that President Biden
has said so little about this he did
very briefly mention it uh near the top
of his remarks and he showed an air
quality chart and they put out a tweet
and a statement talking about how they
sent firefighters to Canada to try to
help put it out but this is something
that affects millions of high-risk
people when we were dealing with covid
even when covid was not at a peak uh
they talked about risks to high uh to
vulnerable parts of the population
elderly folks babies you don't hear
anything from this White House about go
stay inside maybe that's because they
know that it is politically a bad time
for him to tell people to go back inside
their houses after the covet lockdowns
of a couple years ago but but he has
said so little about some something that
affects so many people and considering
the fact that yesterday so about 30
hours ago probably around the time that
he woke up I was standing right here and
having a hard time uh like swallowing
because my mouth was so dried out from
this stuff uh he he just has not
addressed it it's something that affects
him he lives right here I don't I don't
know if he's been outside right since it
got here we haven't seen him outside
they were supposed to have some party
last night or rather tonight and it's
been postponed to Saturday I don't know
if he's actually gone out but he can
turn on the TV and see that it looks
like the the mothership just landed in
Manhattan it really it's it's amazing
the scenes are really amazing um Peter
thank you so much for bringing us up to
speed with all that really appreciate it
yeah thanks for having me Mr Ducey one
of the top reporters in America there
well British Signet was in the U.S the
top British leadership on artificial
intelligence just days after one of his
top advisors warned that AI could begin
to kill humans within two years it
follows an open another signed by Elon
Musk and hundreds of the biggest names
in Tech calling for an urgent pause in
the development of AI well Mo gaudat
who's a former Chief business officer at
Google X was among the first to raise
the alarm he says the situation is
beyond emergency remote author of scary
smart which is a scarily smart book by
the way joins me now Mo great to see you
thank you so much you were part of this
uh quite secretive Google X Group which
I presume you would your job to think
the unthinkable about stuff like Ai and
you very quickly were out of the traps
to warn people look this is serious what
was it that you saw where you thought
okay we've got to be really careful now
we had a tiny bit of an experiment that
was about teaching robotic arms to grip
items that were some funny
developer used children toys in front of
those arms and and basically they kept
trying for weeks without any success
whatso ever and I passed by them and I
was thinking we wasted so much money on
something that wasn't going to work on a
Friday evening one of them gripped one
yellow ball showed it to the camera and
basically I was like there you go
millions of dollars for one yellow ball
Monday morning every one of them was was
gripping one year every yellow Ball by a
few weeks later every one of them was
gripping everything the speed that at
which those machines were learning is
staggering but at the same time uh the
the understanding we have about why they
learn why they do what they do is very
very limited is that
self-designing what they were doing they
basically are mimicking human
intelligence and the reason I asked that
is I interviewed Professor Stephen
Hawking just before he died his last
television interview and I asked him
what is the biggest threat to Mankind
and he said intelligence let me show you
the clip we've got to hear of it
ever since the start of the Industrial
Revolution there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
instead the demand for goods and
services has risen in line with the
increased capabilities
whether this can continue indefinitely
it's an open question but there is a
greater Danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly when we may lose control
it seems very prescient now that was a
few years ago yeah I mean that was
President this is really what you're
talking about I I left in 2018 a warning
in my first video that I issued after
after I left was all about that and the
idea that you know we always had three
uh boundaries if you want for AI we said
don't put them on the open internet
until you solve the control problem
don't teach them to code because that
makes themselves develop and don't have
other AIS prompting them other agents
working with them and we've crossed all
three lines I mean I remember with chat
I'm a big chess player fan not great but
I like playing it and I remember when
deep blue I think that's the first you
won against Gary Casper right that was
it and to start with the grand Masters
beat the first ones and then suddenly
deep blue one and then it got completely
invincible and now now again never again
did the human win well no human can beat
it even the greatest players like Casper
so that showed me how quickly
robots technology computers can LeapFrog
past human brains let's stick with
gaming alphago was designed by deepmind
actually here in the UK amazing amazing
team to to win in the game strategy game
of go right uh it took them months and
months and months and a couple of
versions to win and be the world
champion if you want then they had
alphago Master learn the the game
without ever watching a human player
play they the alphago master learned by
playing against itself within three days
it won against the first version within
21 days it won a thousand to zero
against the world champion which was
already an AI do you understand that the
speed at which they are learning so look
that taught me through timings here
because people have been calling experts
in this letter calling for a six-month
pause but if if nothing is paused if we
carry on at the rate that we're going at
the moment what could happen
the reality in my personal view is that
it is very difficult to predict
something could happen tomorrow or in
four years or in five years I wouldn't
say later than 2029 most of our
predictions and when you when you say
something what do you mean what is the
worst case scenario
beginning of the worst case scenario is
that they are smarter than us so they
are not controllable right and the thing
that what would they do then what would
artificial intelligence do once it
becomes smarter than human beings would
it see would it see us human entities as
pointless there are two stages of threat
right and I think the biggest challenge
we have in the world today is we're
focused on the existential threat that
we saw in science fiction movies The
Closer threat is much worse right this
is an Oppenheimer moment the one that
controls AI has enormous power over
everyone else right and basically that
means that everyone who doesn't control
AI today is in an arms race trying to
take control of the this is why when I
think of the prime minister's move it's
a great move over you almost when you
think about it but so difficult to
achieve because you have to unify China
Russia and the U.S right to make to be
able to to regulate I mean a
well-intentioned person trying to
regulate and control AI we give it
morality that's the whole point but but
a nefarious controller of AI presumably
could teach it to be immoral the
opposite which is happening as we speak
there's absolutely no doubt if you tell
the drug lords of the world and the
criminals of the world that AI is a
super powerful tool they're finding the
way a way to hack your bank as well it's
scary it is very very concerning and I
think the reality is interestingly the
only way you can defend against the
super intelligence is through another
Super intelligence which is what creates
that prisoner's dilemma what I call the
first inevitable inevitable and scary
smart is that is that we have to
continue the development because if uh
you know it falls in the wrong hands we
want the right hands to have power to
the Defenders right at the same time
that complexity of the situation is
entirely about morality and ethics and
and interestingly the latest development
of something like Chad GPT for example
is using reinforcement learning which is
a very interesting technique because it
basically allows a human to interface
with chat GPT and say that was the wrong
answer can you go back and think about
what it is the challenge is almost like
you're teaching a child to school a
hundred percent and you you know in
reinforcement learning I mean in a
simplified way we're basically telling
the machine to revisit its algorithm so
that the answer becomes a cat not a bird
right also we can tell it that answer is
immoral can you
revisit your algorithm so that you
become again the problem I see is that
you if you're well intentioned doing
this process yes that's one thing if
you're teaching it deliberately to be
immoral yes very quickly you could get
out of control AI which has very
unpleasant tendencies
my very clear statement is that I
honestly am not concerned with the
machines even though the existential
threats are possible you're concerned
with what humans teach I'm concerned
with humans with AI and they're not I
totally agree with you yeah let's end on
a happier note it actually starts on a
desperately unhappy note but you have
this awful thing in your life where your
son
but in for a routine operation and ended
up dying through a series of Errors made
by the medical team
and out of it you could have fallen
apart like a lot of people may have done
in that situation but you turned it into
a huge extraordinary positive tell me
what you did
I I don't know honestly I felt in a very
interesting way
that my son should not have left the
world for no reason that I could never
bring him back it was it was four hours
Pierce between between the moment he
hugged me and went into that operating
room to the minute he left our world all
together four hours and you have to get
to a point where you say what do I do
with this what do I fall apart and then
on my desk bed is still not here or do I
try to do something that reminds the
world of his Essence and and believe it
or not everything I've done since since
2014 has been influenced by by what that
young man taught me and in a very
interesting way this my work on AI and
artificial intelligence my work on
happiness my work on stress but tell me
about the work on happiness specifically
I I found a happiness equation basically
but you know when you deal with
Engineers who are weird people so so
when I was very unhappy as a young man I
couldn't actually find my happiness
through the teachings of you know sages
and gurus and so on and I had to give
myself a practical mathematical way of
looking at it I took that I discussed it
with my son he taught me the hard side
of it and then I I Pro you know I wrote
my first book salt for happy which
basically was based on that based on an
idea that happiness is very logical that
if you can control your brain to have an
interesting conversation with you I can
also control my brain to become a little
happier right maybe not to become
absolutely happy but to become a little
happier right and and that got a lot of
acceptance all for happy was an
international bestseller everywhere and
and basically because the modern world
as we know it is here it's no longer
here and so you know my first mission
was 10 million happy which was an
attempt to make the world remember Ali
if you want and then my second mission
one billion happy was 100 of because of
AI amazing yeah and ultimately actually
it comes back again to the human brain
100 and the key denominator here whether
it's dealing with AI whether it's
dealing with your ability to feel
happiness actually in the end it's about
the human brain it's about being human
yes brain and heart intuition and
Analysis it's about being human no it's
fantastic to talk to you thank you very
much for coming in scary smart the
future of AI and how you can save our
world well it couldn't be a more
important book at a more important time
thank you very much for coming in thank
you for having me will be joined live in
the studio by Gene Simmons the Kiss rock
legend if that doesn't keep you watching
then honestly I have no hope for you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
this is exciting for me I'm joined by
Rock royalty Gene Simmons from Kiss how
are you how are you young man it was
great to have you here thank you in the
UK in London in my studio in your studio
we go back a long way we do we do
Celebrity Apprentice what I knew it 2008
and just to remind anyone left in the
world I haven't told which one of us won
go on I do yes he did but only because
you quit early and if you hadn't you'd
have beaten me well that's not so but
you're you're very bright and good
looking
now that is the case you know what you
can come back anytime Gene Simmons
you're a very kind now you're tall it's
it it's
signaling that it may be the end no it
is it is you've got to have you know at
some point we're all grown-ups you've
got to be able to understand when the
curtain comes down everything's got to
come to an end at some point have a
little dignity and self-respect love
your fans and understand when it's time
to graciously thank them for an amazing
journey that's lasted because I really
walk away from the states yes really
because the alternative is staying on
the stage too long the way who's who has
gone on too long in your estimation oh
many many perhaps you want me to name
and shame
who have you looked at hang on come on
it's time it's not fair you could look
you can you can see them by the number
of creases on their face and so on
Rock basically is a young man's
generally speaking uh form of music and
look half a century is plenty of time to
put on more makeup and wear higher heels
than your girlfriend we've done this a
long time December the second is going
to be the last time and we we would love
to see those few tickets remaining if
there are any yeah some of our friends
uh in London at the O2 it's going to be
the last time we will ever play really
that's it yeah we want to play indoors
instead of usually we headline download
or used to be called Monsters of Rock uh
we wanted a more sort of uh emotional
thing because it is what's been for you
I mean if I could let you relive one
moment of your entire rock career right
now which one would you choose
I would choose the beginning the very
first time we ever got up on stage
fourth on the build New Year's Eve 1973
in New York City
my heart was pumping like uh nothing you
ever saw because you have to understand
when you come from the loins of the
people you know sort of come up on the
streets and you you see these sort of
god-like figures on stage having the
time of their lives being adored there's
no other plumbers don't get that even
the pope doesn't get knickers thrown in
this video
do you might but I'm going to get in
trouble
but this astonishing lifestyle and I was
never the best looking guy and all that
stuff but soon as you start strumming
the guitar and of course sticking out my
prodigious oral appendage how is the
tongue oh it's very can we have a great
flash I would but the floor is dirty
thank you for that thank you as being a
rock star as it lived up to everything
you hoped it would be it's more than
that it's just so many people moan about
their life in Show Business oh it's so
you've never you've never moaned about
he thinks they protest too much of your
famous writers said that it's nonsense
how would you like to be have more money
than you know what to do with have more
adoration oh I forgot you're a pierce
more you get that everything thank you
Gene
uh I want to talk about someone else is
in town Roger Waters Pink Floyd you're
obviously Jewish he's been coming out
with all this is really and Israeli and
he's becoming a lot of very anti-israel
uh and what people perceive to be
anti-semitic comments I'm not sure
that's the same thing right so so what's
your position about Roger Waters well
first of all he's a very talented guy
he's written some of the most wonderful
music along with Floyd
um many many decades and it's obviously
held up and he's got lots of fans
there is something to be said for
keeping your political and other beliefs
off the stage his choice is to use the
stage as a platform to further his point
of view there is a difference between a
political statement about Israel and
about anti-Semitism by the way
anti-Semitism also involves Arabs the
the definition of a Semite includes the
Arab world so I think is a well-meaning
guy I don't agree with his point of
views of course so do you think he's
anti-semitic or do you think he's
anti-israel I think he is from my point
of view
inflamed angry about the political
situation as we all are you want there
to be peace someplace and look I turn my
our attention to this wonderful fairy
tale of a country uh or their
leprechauns and so on Ireland the North
and the South yes it's been ongoing for
God knows how long and the divisions are
deep if you're either Protestant or
Kathleen or different and I've visited
uh Parliament there we're going to come
to that she offers a break I just want
to play a little clip this is Roger
Waters today he popped up doing some
interview and he said this
my story is yet another story of cancer
culture why are they trying to cancel
Roger Waters why aren't a real
journalists going hang on a minute this
is maybe I'll call up and see what he
has to say why aren't you Piers Morgan
hey
well you know the truth is Roger we have
for the last two years at Piers Morgan
says well actually about 18 months six
months before we came on air and since
we've been on air we have repeatedly
asked you these are all the stuff that
we're showing on screen now all the
requests and back came the response
saying no not available can't do it too
busy on stage off stage so Roger you
need to talk to your people because
you've had a standing offer to come on
Piers Morgan uncensored the entire time
we've been on air look I'd like to jump
in just for a quick second the best way
to have a discussion or even an argument
is find Common Ground yeah and then and
then get into the diversions of what you
think so what we agree with and I'm
Israeli and Jewish my mother was in a
concentration camp in Nazi Germany and
so on and so forth I'm not saying this
to get your your
hard burping anyway we we agree there
absolutely should be an Arab State
Palestine no question about it it should
exist side by side with Israel no
question about it there should be free
flow of information and commerce and so
on
okay so it doesn't exist now let's work
together to try to make it happen so
what's the problem
if only it were that easy Gene but you
know as always you have a lot of clarity
about these things that's why I like you
let's have a short break we'll come back
and talk about well Britain and our
Parliament you were there yesterday we
fainted like a quite rightly like a rock
God being baked for selfies by
politicians but what do you think of our
system what do you think of him Boris
Johnson the shambles as we call him
we'll have more from Gene Simmons after
the break
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk four children
fight for their lives after a knife
attack at a playground in France
Rishi sunak and Joe Biden commit to a
new special relationship in sunax first
visit to the United States as prime
minister and police vowed to attend all
burglaries in a new commitment to
prioritizing crime that's all at nine
o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh
Adrian told to be a presenter Richard
Tice and the rock legend that is Gene
Simmons well gee yesterday you were in
the heart of our British Parliament why
what were you doing there well a uh
beloved and respected MP invited me as a
matter of fact as a statement of fact
there he is
Junior his dad is a legend of course uh
I was invited to come by and visit the
house of comet and so on and so we have
a jet we travel on it we were playing
Newcastle and all the airports were
closed because Mr zielinski from Ukraine
was here and for political reasons there
so I called up and I said you know I
can't come because we can't land our jet
there was a phone call made
by the MP by the respected MP and all of
a sudden we were the only jet allowed to
land in London
what's up
and we landed and of course I I will
tell you I I was a sixth grade school
teacher in New York in Spanish Harlem
before I stuck out my tongue for a
living and uh to to try to make 12 year
olds and 13 year olds understand in New
York City
this astonishing Little Island little by
American comparisons where a monarchy
has existed for over a thousand years
The Amazing Stories the characters and
so on and how this kind of transference
of power of course the Star Chamber and
you know King Henry VII who wouldn't get
it like all this juicy historical stuff
and then Guy Fawkes notwithstanding he
didn't quite get there but democracy
came forth in full bloom and I saw it
firsthand
with you know sitting there respectfully
and silently and watch it and I will
tell you there's a bit of Civility
missing in American politics because the
fine gentleman uh is addressing it I
would like to say in essence you're full
of stuff
it was all very respectful well you
mentioned the point because they call
each other the right honorable gentleman
Richard's eyes we have a situation now
where Boris Johnson's honors list is
about to be approved by Rishi sunak I
don't think anyone who's been
dishonorable and had to quit in shame
and disgrace and broken the law and be
fined by the police and so on I don't
think they should have an honors list
well I mean that's the that's the
convention the really the reality is a
Deal's been done suneck has said okay
you can have your honors list as long as
you just lay off give me a break you do
your thing and then I suspect there's a
deal being done with regard to the party
gate inquiry so this is what's happened
behind closed doors just Mark well he's
now had his report Paula today Boris
Johnson about the party getting choir
and if it goes the wrong way for him
he's got two weeks to respond it goes
the wrong way that could be the end of
his political career well we know that
he's had a had a warning letter as well
don't we in terms of that of that
investigation but you talk about his
political career what political career
even when he was in politics could
anyone really say that he had a
political career he bumbled through
various different mistakes and we we
know that he has left us in such a
derisory position in terms of where we
are on the world uh scale no who who
respects us they're laughing what are
you making Boris Gene well you have to
uh you have to consider that I'm
Outsider and the view from far away is
decidedly different than being in the
thick of it all I'm a big fan of Boris
the body politic worldwide is really as
far as I'm concerned what the story is
about you've either got the the ability
to confer with and make deals worldwide
that then benefits the UK and the
various countries they're in or you
don't BB Netanyahu
and where has he been for his
constituents and there's been a recent
poll that suggests he's going to lose
his seat he's gone by the way I love
watching Paula arguing with Gene Simmons
I don't get this anymore
my just oil protest if I'd have known
that you've got fish
[Music]
not too late
I just I just want to quickly put in
right now the people's business is being
done by Mr sunak in Washington DC
because there's a momentous and never
before done deal with the UK and America
and I'm sure the news uh people will be
uh reporting on that what I mean to say
is that Mr sunac is in Washington D.C so
perhaps I saw his Deputy the House of
Commons addressing certain issues it's
the big story folks the world is is as
far as I'm concerned the body politic
yes there will always be unions who
complain I don't have enough social
security stuff and right you can pay
attention to that but there's a big
story and as far as I'm concerned Boris
was a great communicator perhaps locally
was not as uh all right well let's talk
about your own backyard because you and
I when we competed together on Celebrity
Apprentice the person that chose me as
the winner was Donald Trump I said if I
mentioned that enough but he became
president of the United States and he at
the moment is Rory your head in the
polls to become Republican nominee given
the state of Joe Biden right now uh even
calling our prime minister Mr President
today you couldn't bet against Trump
getting reelected could you there is a
decent chance you have to understand
that America is physically larger than
Europe and in the same way that the UK
is not one group of people you've got
the Celts and the pits in different
languages different accents and so on
and so forth and of course lots of new
folks from around the world coming here
so it's not one people America likewise
New York and La is not Wisconsin and
Nebraska who's going to win the American
election
give me a name Donald Trump wow wow we
can ignore all the cases we can ignore
the indictments we can ignore the
sections
he wasn't making a judgment he just said
he thinks he's going to win I'm not even
saying that I'm for it but I will tell
you I was Mr Trump and I Mr Biden I
think is an ethical man and so on I call
both Mrs but somebody is going to run a
30-second Sizzle reel showing Mr Biden
falling down totally agree I totally
agree that's what Gene we've run out of
time I wish I'd had you on for longer
please come back soon kiss are playing
5th of July in London seventh July
Manchester 8th July in Glasgow they're
back in December at the O2 it's the end
of Kiss he says I don't want to believe
this
kiss should never end
it should be forever forever long going
like your tongue
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]